مشاهد لم نعتد رؤيتها منذ 50 عاما ولها
الاثر الكبير في تغيير قواعد الحرب
والتفاوض جنود اسرائيليون بينهم قاده كبار
يقادون الى الاسر باعداد كبيره بعضهم
بلباسه العسكري واخرون بلباس
مدني لم يدر في خلد احدهم انه سياتي يوم
يتمكن فيه المقاومون في غزه من اجتياز
سياج مزود باحدث تقنيات الرصد ويبغون في
داخل قاعدتهم او في دباباتهم او في
مهاجعهم ربما كانت هذه المشاهد اكثر قسوه
على الاسرائيليين من صور الدماء والقتل
التي اعتادوها ودفعت بعض اهالي الاسرى الى
الدعوه الى الانتقام بشده وقطع الماء
والكهرباء والطعام عن غزه وتدمير القطاع
عن
اهله يا ووجي وين
لا يعرف حتى الان عدد الذين اسرتهم
المقاومه من عسكريين ومدنيين لكن ابو
عبيده المتحدث باسم كتائب عز الدين القسام
اكد ان العدد الاجمالي للاسرائيليين الذين
اسرتهم الحركه في عمليه طوفان الاقصى اكثر
مما اعلن رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه
بنيامين نتنياهو باضعاف
مضاعفه والسؤال الذي يثار الان ما مصير
هؤلاء الاسرى قناه الاخبار الثانيه عشره
في التلفزيون الاسرائيلي نقلت عن مصدر
سياسي ان مصر تجري حوارا احادي الجانب مع
حركه حماس من اجل اطلاق كبار السن
والاطفال المحتجزين في قطاع غزه لاسباب
انسانيه لكن سرعان ما كذب هذا الخبر قد
تسعى اسرائيل خلال حربها الواسعه على غزه
الى تحرير بعض اسرا في محاوله لاعاده بعض
الهيبه الى اجهزتها الاستخباراتيه وجيشها
لكن المعضله التي تواجهها ان كتائب القسام
قد وزعتهم على جميع محاور القطاع وستجد
نفسها مضطره في النهايه الى التفاوض مع
حماس لتحرير اسرها من الاحياء والقتلى لكن
الثمن هذه المره سيكون اكبر بكثير من صفقه
شاليط ولن يكون المقابل تبييض السج
الاسرائيليه من الفلسطينيين بل قد يتجاوزه
الى مكاسب اخرى لاهل القطاع المحاصر
والقدس
والضفه